non ces mesures d' emmanuel macron sont
elles à la hauteur at il trouvé les mots
peuvent elles être efficace c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
et pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec anouar kbibech président du
rassemblement des musulmans de france
bonsoir noir kbibech merci d'être avec
nous à ses côtés également george
kaufmann au beach président de la
république souveraine bonsoir merci à
vous également d'être là alors on va
s'arrêter sur la sémantique parce que
manifestement c'était un aspect
extrêmement important de ce discours
attendu des manuels macron qui s'était
pas exprimé sur le sujet depuis un petit
moment
lutter contre le séparatisme islamiste
est ce que cette appellation et j'avoue
semble approprié anouar kbibech
effectivement enfin en parler avant de
communautarisme mais effectivement il ya
qu une seule communauté qui va et ce à
la communauté nationale
par contre ça pouvait effectivement
prêter à confusion parce qu'il ya des
communautés de langue des communautés de
religions diverses et variées le mot
sépara si ces paroles séparatisme et est
encore plus fort parce qu'il ya une
notion de rupture de rupture par rapport
à la société de rupture par rapport aux
valeurs de la république et qui n'est
pas forcément d'ordre religieux même si
le président de la v de la république
parle du séparatisme d'origine islamiste
mais je pense que la notion de
séparatistes ont peut être peut
s'appliquer à plusieurs autres
phénomènes qui peuvent être d'ordre
social économique et pas seulement
religieux complétant une bonne chose
pour vous
la réplication et une levée d'ambiguïté
jarjat kossmann au vide c'était
important on l'attendait aussi sur les
mots on a parfois reproché au président
de ne pas nommer les choses ça me
convient cette appellation elle est
approprié mais c'est de faire bref mais
entendre dans les mots dans la bouche du
président la république
emmanuel macron le thème de séparatisme
me pose un vrai problème
problème parce que
il fait partie d'une caste économique
qui est la première à séparer de la plus
française en détruisant le socle
national sur lequel repose notre pays
depuis le conseil national de résistance
et je pense à tout ce qui fait la seule
idée de solidarité nationale
on le voit récemment encore avec cette
réforme de retraites qui va passer en
force contre l'ensemble du peuple et
contre le conseil y compris contre le
conseil d'état donc là on a un véritable
séparatisme qui renvoie aux travaux de
l'américain christopher lasch qui
parlait de la trahison des élites on a
une caste qui trahi son peuple
jusqu à l'huile tirée massivement
l'arrêté massivement comme ça a été le
cas avec les gilets jaunes
maintenant effectivement il y à un
courant de l'islam politique radicale
qui est séparatiste en france et
ailleurs je rappelle qu'il frappe
d'abord les pays de religion ou de
culture musulmane en premier avant les
pays occidentaux mais ce sont des gens
qui ont une ce sont des politiques sont
des gens qui ont une vision politique et
religieuse globale et qui sont en guerre
totale contre tous ceux qui ont une
autre vision
donc en france effectivement il faut les
combattre par par tous les moyens
mais moi je préfère quand même parler de
communautarisme parce que c'est un terme
qui est entendu accepté par tous et là
il ya quand même un souci de la part d'
emmanuel macron parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est influencer
considérablement et dans bien des
domaines par les états unis où on a le
monde anglo saxon c'est un monde
communautariste et on l'a bien vu avec
dans bien des cas avec ce gouvernement
et van hamme belloubet qui est qui a eu
du mal sur la ferme il a commencé à
parler aux parents de faire de blasphème
massy en france
malheureusement pour certains mais c'est
ce pays où on peut ou on peut place mais
si on a envie contre toutes les
religions ont là qui est de haute lutte
contre les religions catholique contre
catholicisme politique c'est également
le quand il a été nommé quand il a été
élu par don fascinant république il a
nommé un certain yacine
bela tarr qui s'illustrent justement
dans cette séparation
ce communautarisme et je pense que c'est
ce communautarisme qui doit être
combattue et donc pas que pas que celui
de certains islamistes mais l'ensemble
de ceux qui veulent distinguer les
français en rappelant que nous sommes
une république une et indivisible
la porte parole du gouvernement avait
pris des précautions déjà dès ce matin
le séparatisme ne doit pas être
mélangées avec l'aspect le problème de
la laïcité nous partager ce constat est
également oui tout à fait déjà des gens
quand on parle de séparatisme je pense
qu'il ne faut pas en déduire qu'il faut
stigmatiser au pointé du doigt
l'ensemble des citoyens français de
confession musulmane comme j'ai dit tout
à l'heure ce n'est pas lié à une
religion en particulier même s'il ne
faut pas être dans le déni et à certains
qui ont une lecture étriqué de la
religion musulmane qui essaie
d'instrumentaliser qui essayait de la
dévoyée par quelques comportements mais
heureusement c'est une infime minorité
et il faut vraiment éviter de
généraliser
donc les musulmans de france sont
d'abord des citoyens à part entière et
non des citoyens entièrement à part ils
seront d'abord des citoyens avant d'être
des musulmans ils sont respectueux des
valeurs et des lois de la république et
il s'inscrit totalement dans la
république laïque une et indivisible
qu'on vous disiez et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire confiance
aux musulmans de france bien sûr il ya
des phénomènes très ciblée qu'il faut
combattre par la prévention c'est le
rôle des institutions religieuses
c'est aussi le rôle de l'état justement
par un certain nombre de lois du
disposition pour combattre ce
séparatisme
mais il faut surtout pas généraliser je
pense que le président de la république
a su trouver cet équilibre ce en même
temps ou à la fois ils dénoncent et
nomme les choses mais également il est
dans une démarche de rassemblement de la
communauté nationale et et en essayant
d'éviter de pointer du doigt une
religion en particulier aux des citoyens
et certaines constructions en
particulier sur ce que peut-être qu'on
serait pas d'accord j'imagine c'est
pense en ce moment en silence il est une
religion par l'ensemble la religion mais
dès les éléments de l'islam politique
qui pousse au conflit c'est bien dans la
région dans dans l'islam comme ça a été
le cas avec les catholiques et jeux
comme ça a été le cas avec atelier
lecture des voiliers ou d'une
instrumentalisation cialis si vous
voulez mais là c'est pas le problème la
république de déterminer qui
théologiquement raison n'a pas raison
c'est juste que chacun quelle que soit
sa religion accepte les règles la
république
et si les axes et accepte pas on fait
comme mon affaire entre 1880 et 1905 jeu
même avant des délices et 189 ont fermé
congrégation et les gens mettent un
genou à terre et prête serment devant la
constitution ils acceptent les valeurs
de la république où ils s'en vont
et d'ailleurs beaucoup de catholiques
d'alors dans les congrégations était
fermé leurs biens ont été prises qu'on
le rappelle c'est extrêmement dur ce
combat sont partis en belgique en
allemagne pour parce que là bas ils
n'avaient plus le droit de vivre de
manière communautariste avec des grandes
croix et qui jésus partout c'est un peu
la même chose avec l'islam et là où je
viens pas d'accord et vous c'est que
quand vous avez présidé le cfcm vous
avez poussé au port du voile
or le port du voile pour moi qui suis à
un laïc a c'est assez radical
c'est une forme de séparation de ma
maman maman était dans les années 60 est
levée par les bonnes soeurs de la
doctrine chrétienne
à 14 ans elle était intimement convaincu
que le ciel ça c'est derrière monsieur
dans un bus allaient tomber enceinte je
pense que c'est une très très mauvaise
idée que des gens en particulier que les
femmes ou parce qu'une semaine à public
où il l égalité entre les femmes mettent
des idées saugrenues dans la tête des
femmes ou les sépare du reste de la
communauté puisque le voile est une
séparation du reste de la communauté
avec l'idée qui est quand même assez
étonnante surtout si on regarde le cas
grippaux en ce moment que les femmes
sera responsable de l'excitation qu'elle
provoquerait auprès des hommes voilà ça
je pense qu'il faudrait combattre
un prix sans vous permettez vous avez
commencé par rappeler qu'on est dans une
république laïque la laïcité à ce que je
sache c'est la garantie de la liberté de
conscience la liberté de croire et de ne
point quoi et c'est la garantie c'est
l'état qui lui doit la garantir que pour
tout citoyen croyant une palabre à
chausser également de pouvoir vivre
pleinement sa religion dans le respect
des lois et des valeurs de la république
a bien évidemment et ses essais et c'est
le cas de l'immense de la quasi-totalité
des musulmans de france qui sont
respectueux des valeurs et des lois
république ce que vous avez dit
également c'est que la république et le
présenta république l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est la république est laïque
ce n'est pas la société qui est laïque
et d'ailleurs il a le frison de la
république a dit que le port du voile ou
de signes religieux dans l'espace public
c'est pas son affaire enfin si c'est le
mot qu'il avait qu'il avait utilisé par
contre la laïcité effectivement ça la
neutralité des services de l'état
c'est une autre réalité des agents de
l'état pas des usagers des services
publics mais des agents des services
publics tels alors l'exemple du voile
c'est il relève du choix de chacun femme
huang de ce qu'on irait de se conformer
à tel ou tel précis prescription
religieuse mais il ne faut pas faire
d'amalgamé entre les choix
vestimentaires que peuvent prendre untel
ou untel et notamment les femmes est
elle à pied sont l'égalité enfants moi
je vous rejoins entièrement que il fera
sur et une égalité parfaite entre les
hommes et les femmes avec les mêmes
droits et les mêmes devoirs et je sais
que la religion musulmane les
interpeller régulièrement là dessus et
quand j'étais président du cfcm j'avais
eu gré pour que des femmes soient au
sein du cfcm
nous avons créé une instance de dialogue
avec des fins pour pouvoir être à leur
écoute être à jeudi répondre à leurs
attentes et prendre en compte leurs
oeufs leurs propositions donc je pense
que nous devons nous améliorer l'action
intéressant ce conte et anouar kbibech
parce que le gouvernement justement veut
s'appuyer sur le cfcm a le conseil
français du culte musulman
qu'est ce que ça a donné vos efforts
pour rétablir une forme d'égalité on a
vu quand même que cfcm s'était illustré
ça a été critiqué lors de la ferme il a
il faisait référence
en gros l'a bien cherché c'était ce café
oise a été la déclaration du conseil
français du culte musulman ça vous
attriste ce genre de sortie d'audience
le cfcm a pris conscience justement que
la religion musulmane était
régulièrement interpellé au sein de la
société française et par les autorités
par les différents partis politiques et
l'ensemble des concitoyens sur l'égalité
hommes-femmes et là dessus il ya des
propositions concrètes qui ont été
formulées et aujourd'hui à des femmes
qui sont rentrés pour la première fois
au conseil d'administration du cfcm et
j'espère bientôt au bureau du safe c'est
donc bien des avancées
maintenant la ferme il a effectivement
elle a donné lieu à plusieurs
interprétations à plusieurs prises de
position je pense que la question du
blasphème a été réaffirmée la
possibilité de blasphème a été
réaffirmée par plusieurs responsables
politiques ou religieux et globalement
je pense qu'on est dans un thé dans un
pays de la liberté d'expression il faut
respecter la liberté des uns et des
autres mais c'est également la liberté
d'un croyant quand il voit sa propre
religion insulté de dire qu'il est
blessé
alors bien sûr ça ne n'excusent en aucun
cas où nous semble justifié au grain cas
des appels au meurtre aux désirs et les
différents cultes qui ont déferlé sur
les réseaux sociaux mais par contre il
faut effectivement puis pouvoir
construire ce vivre ensemble entre les
différents points de vue dont le respect
de la liberté d'expression des uns et
des autres alors on va aller dans le
coeur du sujet on va les écouter
emmanuel macron qui a fait quelques
annonces tout de même emmanuel macron
qui a souhaité a annoncé qu'il
souhaitait arrêter le système des imams
un détachées pour former des imams
directement sur le sol français
aujourd'hui on a je le disais 300 imams
détachées qui sont envoyées en france
chaque année
et donc ce qu'ils sont et 20 en 2020
seront la dernière génération avec ce
volume et nous allons progressivement
sortir c'est à dire ne plus en faire
venir de nouveaux et laisser la période
de présence des dernier imam détachées
se poursuivre jusqu'à son terme avec là
aussi un dialogue une amélioration
des conditions en parallèle de sa ce que
nous devons faire est ce que nous allons
faire c'est g revenir dans un instant
former des imams en france pour qu'ils
puissent maîtriser la langue et les lois
de la république
donc nous allons ainsi progressivement
mettre fin au système des imams
détachées et là aussi de manière
progressive
opsahl moddeurs qui sont accueillis
spécifiquement chaque année à l'occasion
du ramadan
il y en a environ 300 cette sortie de ce
qu'on appelle l'islam consulaire est
elle aussi extrêmement importante pour
pouvoir réduire ses influences
étrangères
et là aussi permettre de s'assurer que
chacune et chacun respecte pleinement
les lois de la république dans un cadre
qui est connu de tous
georges que ce banovic c'est la bonne
voie que prend emmanuel macron arrêté
système d ea même détachée notamment
arrêté de l'influencé étrangère
oui ça peut rester c'est pour rester
lettre morte
et puis c'est pas la seule ne s'est pas
la seule mesure c'est pas la seule
mesure à prendre
j'ai toujours un peu circonspect avec
monsieur macron sur ces questions là je
vous le dit tout à l'heure
monsieur maquereau et le président de la
république française donc de tous les
français même s'il a été élu que par une
petite partie d'entre eux du premier
tour il est censé défendre la laïcité
or il a été un des premiers à l'avoir
attaqué lorsqu'il est allé rompre l'
iftar ne la souhaitait rencontrer les
protestants de france lorsqu'il va au
ccf pardon cliff au crif voix au crif ou
alors pire encore lorsqu'il est allé
rencontrer les évêques de france alors
qu'il rend compte qu'il veut mais qu'ils
disent aux évêques de france
le lui le lien entre la république à
église a été rompu nous allons leur nous
et c'est justement il a été rompue
c'était l'objectif au monde en 1905 il
ya rien à renouer du tout de la même
manière
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
philippe a déclaré qu'il faudrait une
laïcité apaisée
parce que vous est-ce qu'on serait pour
une liberté apaisé non la laïcité est
laïcité points à lenny apaisé ni modéré
doué on est dans un pays laïque alors
maintenant sur 7 sur cette question des
imams
il me semble je ne suis pas telle vient
du tout ni l'islam et aucune autre
religion mais il me semble que c'est
il n'y a pas vraiment clergé on n'est
pas tout à fait exactement dans l'église
catholique ou orthodoxe
c'est un choix des croyants parmi ceux
qui sont du plus sage la communauté
alors ça ressemble plus au
protestantisme que co catholicisme de ce
point de vue là donc qui va les former
comment par contre monsieur macro
immédiatement aurait pu prononcer deux
mesures s'est gelé les avoirs de
quelques milliards de certains un prince
saoudien jusqu'à ce qu'il dégage par eux
mêmes tous ceux qui l'ont mis ici et
tous leurs prédicateurs qui sont les
vecteurs de du salafisme du thatchérisme
et les renvoyer dans leurs dents où ils
veulent un pays qui veulent de la même
manière exigeait de l'ambassade des
états unis qui les arrêtent leur
financement dans nos cités dans nos
banlieues du communautarisme puisqu'ils
ont une vision sucer leurs droits ils
font ce qu'ils veulent avec leur pays
visiblement ça ne marche pas très bien
en termes de lutte contre le racisme de
et de flingage de 2,2 de gens de couleur
par leur police mais il serait bon
qu'ils les acquis un arrêt net du
financement de ces pays là qui font du
une action de propagande politique qui
est contraire à ce qu'elle applique
française déjà par rapport au président
de la république et des voir et la
laïcité en allant à la rencontre d'un
certain nombre de communautés
spirituelles ou religieuse un j'ai eu
l'honneur en tant que président du cfcm
en juin 2010 est de recevoir le
président de la république pour la
première fois un iftar du cfcm et je
peux vous dire que les citoyens français
de confession musulmane qui sont des
français également ont été très touché
par ce geste du président de la
république est d'ailleurs une partie du
discours qu'a tenu aujourd'hui le
président de la république à mulhouse
il a été tenu devant les représentants
du culte musulman donc c'est la
république effectivement dans le cadre
laïc ne reconnaît aucun culte même nommé
connais aucun culte
les musulmans de france sont là les
protestants de france en la même si les
gâteaux
ces différences connaître et je compte y
le ton corps d'argile choisirait les
évêques dont mais parfois vous verrez
jamais il est venu il a fait passer un
certain nombre de mes ce qu'en dit très
très fort ça à tous les musulmans de
france et ça fait pratiquement une
feuille de route pour les deux derniers
mois c'est une question un peu naïve
mais pourquoi at on besoin de
reconnaissance
peu importe qu'on soit juifs catholiques
bouddhistes c'est un élément qui leur
fut lancé des droits reconnus par le
président c'est un élément de
considération et c'est également un
dialogue républicain qui se passe dans
différentes instances maintenant par
rapport aux dîmes dans les travaux
publics injustement par rapport aux
imams et des ordres religieux
pas du tout parce que le discours qu'a
tenu le président de la république à
l'iftar du cfcm n'est pas n'était pas du
tout un discours religieux s'étaient
qu'est ce qu'apporte la république et ce
qu'attend la société française des
musulmans de france
mais anouar kbibech on revenir sur ces
imams étrangers est pour vous c'est
prendre le problème dans dans le
par le bon bout je sors d nadia rehman a
tout à l'heure me dire mais les images
les plus radicalisées entre guillemets
ce sont des imams français nés en france
et pas forcément ceux qui viennent de
l'étranger ce que ça vous paraît être
pertinent jusqu'au mans il se trouve que
en tant que président du rassemblement
des musulmans de france c'est moi qui
était à l'origine de la venue de 30
imams des trois semaines interdit
qu'est-ce qu'elle entrerait être alors
justement à l'époque
en 2008 nous avons fait un état des
lieux et nous avions un besoin criant un
imam ça se font pas du jour au lendemain
il faut au moins cinq ans pour former un
imam digne de ce nom avec des gens qui
qui doit avoir la vocation de devenir
imam donc le fait de recourir à des
imams détachées et une solution à court
et moyen terme ce n'est pas du tout la
solution cible la solution à long terme
et donc c'était une solution dans
laquelle nous avons pu avancer combler
un certain vide qui existait déjà
comme la nature a horreur du vide à
éviter à des imams autoproclamés devenir
de d'avancer et de conduire la prière et
donc commencé à orienter les fidèles
mais bien sûr on est tous d'accord qu'il
faut des imans franco français formé en
france et c'est l'ensemble des
fédérations musulmanes au sein du
service elle travaille dans ce sens et
femmes est marquée surtout après il ya
deux de deux aspects de la formation il
ya la formation civils et civiques et
aujourd'hui elle est administrée dans
dourdan d une vingtaine d'universités
françaises est soldée par un diplôme
universitaire et puis à la formation
théologique
je suis là par les vous là dessus ce
n'est pas le rôle de l'état de forme sur
le plan théologique
donc c'est le rôle des fédérations
musulmanes et le conseil français du
culte musulman devrait contribuer à
trouver des solutions pour mettre en
oeuvre des formations sur le plan
théologique des images de france en
france et je pense que le cfcm s'y
emploie mais est ce que vous serez
d'accord pour que les imams venant
d'étrangers d'ailleurs français prêtent
serment à la constitution et aux valeurs
de la plus qu il se trouve que quand
j'étais président et pour ceux qui lui
sert mais on a établi une charte de
l'imam dans laquelle tout inna kyssil
cette charte s'engagent à faire une
prière pour la république pendant le à
la prière du monde
c'est pas la question est posée bien
français de confession musulmane
considère que les valeurs et les lois de
la république ne sont pas gérées en
dessous des valeurs évoluent bien
évidemment la plupart et la plupart des
musulmans que je connais ce sont comme
beaucoup de catholiques tout à fait on a
une pratique tout à fait légère de leur
religion familiale et personne ne les
embête et ils n'embêtent personne
n'évoque tout va très bien
non je posais une question très très
clair est ce que vous êtes d'accord que
les imams sont pas des français
musulmans
les imams donc ceux qui vont professé
prête serment doit un constitution et
devant les voleurs d'arsenic
c'est ça pour moi après la formation
c'est pour ça que je parlais de la ville
assure à ce que la chine lâche rien et a
pris l'eau dans la charte bel immeuble
c'est une déclaration solennelle que
l'imam on s'engage sur le discours qui
va porter auprès des fidèles qui soit un
discours respectueux des valeurs et des
lois de la république
donc je vous invite à consulter cette
charge de l'imam donc c'est une
déclaration solennelle
maintenant ce que vous proposez je n'ai
aucun souci pour que les imams le fasse
à condition que les autres ministres de
culte des automobiles et le devance
légal je vous demande parce que c'est ce
que nous avons fait avec les prêtres
catholiques à la blague enfants très
bien les a fait partie beaucoup disent
d'accord mesures discriminatoires
vous avez entièrement raison
il faudrait pas que soit entendu comme
des mesures discriminatoires région
particulière c'est pour ça que
l'histoire est importante sur cette
saison était d'être beaucoup de jeunes
beaucoup de jeunes pensent que la
laïcité ou ces mesures là sont une
action il ya des racistes un forum soit
une action spécifique contre les
musulmans
il est nécessaire de rappeler mais que
que on a été d'abord très très dur avec
les catholiques ils ont prêté serment
c'est la constitution civile du clergé
et certains il ya eu des guerres certes
on est terrifié ça c'est pas ça s'est
pas très bien passé pour tout le monde
musulman sur l'autre mesure qui auront
le moins mais qui quand même est
importante annonce anse la raie d
enseignement en langue étrangère elle qu
en gros on enseignait voilà ça touche
évidemment l'algérien l'italien aussi
mais enfin on sait ce qui est visé
effectivement dans ce discours c'est
voilà le tunisien algérien ça vous
chante ça non je pense que la
proposition du président de la
république va dans le bon sens elle va
dans le sens d'institutionnaliser une un
enseignement des langues d'origine ou de
culture d'origine dans le cadre est
public et le fait d'enseigner par
exemple jack lang propose que la langue
arabe soit une langue parmi les langues
vivantes quand la france dans l'école de
la république c'est également un moyen
pour barrer la route un certain nombre
d'écoles qui musulmane entre guillemets
coraniques ou autres qui n'ont pas
pignon sur rue et dans lesquels on sait
pas très bien ce qui se passe donc le
fait de d'institutionnaliser
l'enseignement de ces langues à travers
des agents de l'état rémunérés par
l'état français et va dans le bon sens
question centrale est fondamentale et
monde combien monsieur macro est
déconnecté de la société française
monsieur macro est l'incarnation le
parangon du néo libéralisme politique
le problème des locaux de ses
professeurs qui viennent de l'étranger
s'est laissé passer en garde fait en
portugais en italien et vous savez
pourquoi parce qu'il ya plus de
financement par la république de deux
futurs professeurs dans ces langues
l'anneau qu'il faut bien se rabattre sur
ce que proposent les ambassades quels
que soient les pays
alors évidemment ce qui aurait un
intérêt à pousser l'islamisme politique
bon bah vous infiltrer deux ou trois
professeurs et ses global bouquet quel
problème
on peut par carat pour le coup il s'agit
pas de religion on peut parfaitement
avoir des agrégés de langue arabe en
français qui passent par universités
françaises et enseigne à l'école
sauf que en étant tenant d'une ligne
libérale économique et moi on a un
président qui dans la continuation des
précédents saborde savoir la république
ne finance pas l'école le financement la
police ne finance pas tous les services
publics saborde l'hôpital et quand
aujourd'hui des jeunes lui ont dit à
mulhouse il faudrait plus de république
et ils ont raison parce que
damon république que témoin de travail
quand on est perdu au fond de sa cité eh
ben on finit dans une communauté quelle
qu'elle soit donc il faut plus de
république sa demande d'arrêter d'obéir
aux critères de convergence de vues
européennes et donc de financer la
réplique française
merci anouar kbibech merci georges cosma
de vie tout d'abord été avec nous c'est
la fin